wenn du noch platz in deinen beten hast
dann nutze den du hast jetzt nämlich
noch die möglichkeit eine ganze menge
gemüse in deinem garten zu pflanzen oder
auszusehen und welche das genau sind das
zeige ich dir heute
[Musik]
fangen wir mal mit den gemüsen an die du
direkt ins beet sehen oder pflanzen
kannst das ist zb die winter erbse die
kann man im oktober noch aussehen
ich sehe da die sollte sie mal aus und
die überwintert im beet das ist so ein
bisschen wie bei knoblauch auch darauf
kommen wenngleich auch noch zu sprechen
die hat vor dem winter dann schon einen
wachstumsvorsprung überwintert im beet
ist also richtig richtig frosthart und
liefert die dann im frühling die
allererste erbsen die trägt schon im mai
das ist richtig früh für erbsen und ist
es super schön in dieser zeit gerade im
mai da hat man nicht viel was man ernten
kann außer vielleicht ein bisschen salat
ein bisschen spinat und noch das ein
oder andere radieschen das vielleicht
schon reif ist aber das wintergemüse ist
zum größtenteils aufgegessen und das
sommergemüse ist noch nicht reif
und da kommt die winter erste wie
gerufen und man hat noch eine kleine
zusätzliche ernte im frühling das ist
übrigens ja viele leute glauben allem
das gar nicht so aber es ist im winter
gar nicht so kompliziert aus dem eigenen
garten zu essen wie im frühling
weil im frühling fährt einem dann auf
einmal das wintergemüse das fängt dann
langsam an zu blühen oder ist einfach
aufgegessen und das ganze sommergemüse
das noch auf sich warten also guter
lücken für da für diese zeit dann ist
jetzt auch die perfekte zeit um winter
zwiebeln zu stecken
du sagst du dir also kleine steck
zwiebeln 17 so netzen zu kaufen
da reicht ein bis zwei netz erreichen da
eigentlich pro person blicke aus die
stecken wir dann jetzt im oktober ganz
normal also immer daran denken die
spitze seite nach oben
flache seite nach unten in den boden und
ehren die dann nächstes jahr schon
früher als die anderen zwiebeln werden
hier auch den ganzen winter über als
frühlingszwiebeln oder beziehungsweise
einfach das zwiebel grün indem wir das
ungefähr 4 cm über dem boden abschneiden
das machen wir nur bei ein paar unserer
zwiebeln also wir suchen uns da unsere
zwiebelpflanzen aus bei denen wir im
winter das zwiebel grünen ernten damit
die anderen schön dicke knollen bilden
können und das ist auch ganz erstaunlich
wie schnell das nach wächst also wie
ernten pro zwiebel ungefähr drei bis
viermal im winter kanzel eines zwiebel
grün weil die so schnell wieder
austreiben wenn man ungefähr 4 cm über
dem boden stehen lässt jetzt ist auch
die perfekte zeit um knoblauch zu
pflanzen da blickst du einfach die
großen knollen aus
anna und verwendet die kleinen 10 hast
du dabei sonst noch beachten musst das
erzähle ich dir da oben da hab ich ja
auch schon ein video darüber gemacht daß
verlinkt ich auch noch mal in der video
beschreibung da bekommst du wirklich die
komplette anleitung zum knobloch
pflanzen mit allem was du da beachten
muss damit du dann ist es ihr
hoffentlich ganz dicke knollen ernten
kannst im freiland kannst du jetzt auch
wunderbar noch winter salat aussehen wie
das funktioniert zeigt ich dir in diesem
video das pack ich auch noch mal in die
video beschreibung wenn du zuerst hier
fertig schauen möchtest das ist super
einfach den ganzen winter über salat aus
dem eigenen garten zu essen wenn man ein
paar sachen beachtet und das finde ich
so so schön die meisten leute die wissen
gar nicht dass man salat eigentlich das
ganze jahr über an bauen kann
den kannst du jetzt auch pflanzen wenn
du salat vorgezogen hat es kommt aber
total auf die sorten an also schau da
auf jeden fall mal vorbei damit du da
die richtigen sorten welt und das auch
ja diesen den salat wenn es dann richtig
kalt wird auch gut vor dem frost
schützen kannst und für diejenigen von
euch die einen vilbel kasten oder im
gewächshaus haben übrigens wenn du kein
freiwild kasten hast ein pauli ein das
ist super einfach und du kannst damit
deine saison einfach enorm verlängern
und auch verfügen im frühling also voll
die empfehlung hier in der stelle das
ist echt ein einfaches bauprojekt was
einem sehr sehr viel bringen kann im
garten im frühbeet kasten oder im
gewächshaus kannst du jetzt nämlich auch
noch spinat aussehen das funktioniert
jetzt auch noch wunderbar ich habe auch
im freiland schon im oktober spinat
ausgesät und das hat gut geklappt aber
da kommt einfach ganz aufs wetter an und
im oktober kann es ja sogar schon die
ersten fröste geben deswegen du kannst
es riskieren wenn du es auch im freiland
probieren möchte ist aber im gewächshaus
oder im briefkasten
hast du da ein bisschen bessere karten
dann kannst du jetzt immer noch
gartenkresse seelen ist ja auch toll
wenn man mal so einen etwas langweiligen
winter salat aufpeppen möchte
das gibt dem ganzen ein bisschen
schärfer oder auch für grüne soße das
ist bei uns hier so eine spezialität ich
weiß nicht ob man das in ganz
deutschland kennt ich möchte auch super
gut drin also gartenkresse kannst du
jetzt auch noch sein cola geht jetzt
auch noch also den kannst du wunderbar
noch in kuwait kasten oder ins
gewächshaus sehen und dann mache ich
super gerne etwas im frühbeet kasten das
sind erbsen triebe dafür nehme ich mir
einfach er
zu saatgut das muss jetzt noch nicht mal
das saatgut von diesem winter erbsen
sein die man jetzt an baut da kannst du
auch normale zuckererbsen neben die sind
oft auch sehr frosthart und dann brauche
ich dann aber nicht um die schulden zu
ernten sondern um das erbsen grün zu
ehren das ist super lecker süß das
schmeckt eigentlich sowie frische erbsen
also ziemlich ziemlich gut und das kann
man dann den ganzen winter über über dem
boden abschneiden ich las da auch
ungefähr 4 cm stehen damit die pflanzen
wieder austreiben können und das ist
eine tolle ergänzung in den kalten
monaten um noch ein bisschen mehr ernten
zu können feldsalat kannst du jetzt auch
noch sehen ich blende euch hier nochmal
diese tolle sorte ein die ich immer an
baue ich glaube ich weiß jetzt auch mit
sie heißt wert gekommen bringen
vielleicht hast du ja nach dem letzten
september aussagen video keinen spinat
oder mangold vorgezogen dann kannst du
dir jetzt wunderbar in den flügel kasten
oder ins gewächshaus pflanzen könnte es
sogar im freiland noch probieren was er
aber wieder so ein bisschen so eine
kritische geschichte aber das kannst du
auf jeden fall riskieren wenn du jetzt
nicht gerade in alpen wo uns die spinat
sorte die ich dir empfehlen würde für
den winter anbau heißt winter riesen
das ist eine sehr forst harte sorte und
bei mangold baue ich am allerliebsten
rainbow an das ist ein ganz bunter
sorten mixed mit mangold in allen
möglichen farben aber da kannst du auch
alle möglichen anderen sorten verwenden
da habe ich noch keine großen
unterschiede feststellen können was die
frostharte angeht aber rainbow ist eben
besonders schön anfang oktober könntest
du es auf jeden fall auch noch riskieren
postel ein auszusehen
das sollte bis ungefähr mitte oktober
noch gut klappen danach würde ich das
aber nicht mehr machen posten sind auch
ein ganz toller leckerer winter salat
super super gesund und ganz mild also da
damit kann man eigentlich alles machen
das schmeckt einfach sehr sehr lecker
und die wachsen auch in den kalten
monaten wunderbar also das ist nur
richtig große empfehlung von mir im
frühling tasten und gewächshaus kannst
du natürlich auch die anderen gemüse die
ich dir für das freiland empfohlen habe
jetzt auch noch säen und pflanzen
was ich aber besonders gerne mache ist
im gewächshaus so ein paar winter steckt
zwiebeln zu stecken und wir dann das
zwiebel grünen ernten einfach weil es da
noch ein bisschen schneller austreibt
als im freiland aber
das funktioniert im freiland auch
richtig gut erzählt mal welche
wintergemüse ihr dieses jahr in ihrem
garten anbaut da wäre ich auf jeden fall
super neugierig ansonsten verlege ich
euch da trieben mein video zum knoblauch
pflanzen das ist also jetzt thema das
kannst du jetzt noch wunderbar machen da
unten zeige ich dir wie du den ganzen
winter über salat aus deinem garten
ernten kannst ansonsten sehen wir uns
nächste woche wieder am samstag um 10
uhr bis dahin tschüss